while the golden knights are already
into the regular season the henderson
silver knights
practiced for the very first time today
sports director chris matthews joins us
live with
more as they open the door to lifeguard
arena for the brand new
american hockey league franchise
exciting news right yeah it really is
christian we think about this hockey in
the desert here continues to grow
henderson has got to be thrilled
with the new multi-million dollar
facility not only
are the community hockey leagues taking
advantage of this new building
that is now home to a pair of nhl size
sheets of ice
but the silver knights will call this
home from now on
it was an historic day because this was
the first practice for the silver
knights first time
the team had worked out together as they
prepare for their february season opener
they've got all the amenities here to be
successful and in fact
having the parent nhl club in the same
city is not only going to help the ahl
team
it's going to really help them be
successful you know just driving around
the city
seeing golden knights license plates
almost everywhere you go and
um you know even getting to wear this
logo uh on our hats for now at least
um it's really cool it's a i think this
is uh this is turned into hockey city i
think they've done a great job
in uh the organization as a whole and uh
making us feel like
we're important down here and they built
this brand new facility for us which is
which is amazing and they're building a
brand new uh home rank i think it's
supposed to open next year so without
seeing a whole lot of the other american
hockey league rinks or facilities
and talking to some of the players is by
far the best in the league here
silver knights are expected to release
their schedule soon their season opens
in about three weeks from now
now the silver knights will play their
first two seasons at the orleans arena
before moving into the new henderson
arena that is scheduled to be completed
in the spring of 2022 boy this really
has turned into a hockey city golden
knights hosting arizona tonight the
fortress
christian it's all about hockey what's
up there thank you so much
now one more note about the golden
knights we're talking about uh arizona
coyotes
this evening the puck drops at seven
o'clock tonight make sure you join us
here at eight news now
at five o'clock for a live report from
t-mobile arena ahead of the game